I'm Master Sergeant Mike andriaco
stationed at Scott Air Force Base
Illinois
I love the fact that blade smithing
brings a balance to my life
this is me living my dream but in front
of
in front of a real big audience
I'm Tech Sergeant Matthew Prentiss
currently in the United States Air Force
stationed out of Grand Forks Air Force
Base what got me into blade smithing was
actually the show with forged and fire
and I kind of told my wife hey you know
I want to do that and she was like yeah
whatever you're not going to do that
I'm retired chief Master Sergeant Joe
stipple I've got over 26 years of
military service
the promising my wife a Hawaii trip I
never did take her on a honeymoon so
when I win this 50 000 there's going to
be a trip in it for my wife absolutely
today in our first round of competition
we'll be making blades inspired by
history and today you Airmen will be
making this blade
in honor of one of the Air Force's most
strategic campaigns you will be forging
a bolo after operation bolo this is a
Filipino farming tool that was also used
for Warfare let's talk a little bit
about steel today I'd like you to make a
sand my blade using mild steel harvested
from the main rotor nuts from
helicopters and one inch round stock W1
steel good luck blade Smiths time starts
now my game plan is I need to get that
W1 drawn out into a usable Billet and
then I need to figure out how I'm going
to work with this retention nut
the oxygen acetylene torch is one of
those tools when I was a kid growing up
working with my dad that was one of the
tools that I was actually able to start
using at a fairly young age it looks
like Joe's done a really good job of
separating his Steels over there
the angle grinder is not working the way
I was expecting to so maybe I can try
something else I'm thinking what about
some kind of hot cut tool
and oh my gosh it's working just like I
wanted it to so I decided to go to the
forge to heat his retention nut and see
if I can hammer it off and that's not
working out for me I finally decide to
instead of using the big Billet take it
over to the chop saw and cut off small
pieces out wow it's got a little a very
little piece it's all you need I got my
W1 pretty much drawn out faster than
I've ever done it my goal at this point
is to get them all tack loaded together
stacked up and ready to go in the Forge
yes I haven't made a blade shape like
this the example has a very clear
definition between where the blade ends
and the handle starts I need to bring
that that bulbous tip so I'm just going
to get it as close as possible Joe is
out ahead of the pack I mean he just has
been doing really good smart work so
there he goes Jose and the quench
I got a good straight blade
I set my first weld it takes flux a
little more throw it back just for an
insurance policy
so now for the first time in the
competition I start trying to shape my
blade
I'm feeling pretty good about the shape
that I'm getting so this is it I need to
get this thing in the clinch
there's a quench from Mike with a really
really hot blade man that thing was the
temperature of the Sun it had and with
that amount of heat I'm gonna be really
surprised if it didn't work what's the
sand my Edge is this
so I go for my clinch I pull my blade
out I realized that the blade didn't
fully Harden
so with four minutes on the clock I go
back in for a second punch
ah
just drop that in there
Matt's plate is laying in the bottom of
his oil drum over there I mean he's
quenched it I put my finger in the oil
almost hot didn't really want to put my
arm in there five four three two one
placement shut down your machines drop
your tools this first round of
competition is over
all right blade Smith congratulations
you've made it into the second round of
this competition now that your blades
have been tempered it's time to turn
them into fully functional bolos by
attaching handles to them additionally
gentlemen three pinholes a lanyard hole
and an acid etch on your blades good
luck your two hour Starts Now for the
handle I decided to go with a tan
Micarta material because it most clothes
socially matches the wood of the
original but the material is just tough
as Nails I gotta get a handle put on
also by flipping the blade upside down I
already can see that it's going to be
much more manageable to grind this bolo
profile out feeling pretty nervous right
now
got my pin handles drilled I mean I'm
getting there and it's somewhat shaped
like this like the bolo oh get in there
I need to get this handle glued up and
then I need to get this knife sharpened
in Matt's mind the whole thing is make a
complete knife if you have time
straightening but you don't want to end
up with a straight knife that doesn't
meet parameters I had a big mess to
start with but by doing a Hollow Grind I
was able to get in where those welds
weren't completed and basically able to
blend the steel and I was able to find
where the welds are right now I'm going
to work on getting the handle finished
up these are chopping knives so it's got
to fit comfortably in the hand real well
okay back to the blade and then I need
to put a final Edge on it
as I'm shaping my handle I realize I
forgot to drill a lanyard hole in the
Micarta
I knew the hole was in the steel itself
and I remembered about where it was shot
in the dark at the drill press
fifty thousand dollars is on the line
here
I nailed it crisis averted
the Tang it's got a slight warp and I
have some pretty big gaps between the
wood and the metal I decide to clamp
everything back together apply some more
glue and then go ahead and just go back
to the grinder and I'm hoping for the
best
[Music]
there's only a couple minutes left
etch that's
etched and it finally hit me that I'm
supposed to etch this blade so I knew I
had to get over the ferric chlora and
get it done
if I don't get this Edge that could be
what sends me home five
five four three two
one
blade Smith shut down your machines drop
your tools stop what you're doing this
second round of competition is over good
job
let's welcome to the flight home at chop
to test the strength and durability of
your bolo blades as well as the overall
construction of your knives I'm going to
be bashing them into these flight
helmets
remember I don't really care what
happens to these brain buckets is what
happens to your bolos it really counts
Mike you're up first you ready let's
crack this nut
[Applause]
well Mike
blade held up really well there's no
evidence
that this Edge has seen a helmet
the one major issue I have is just the
size of this handle it's a little narrow
in this dimension for my hand which
makes it a little bit round and rolly
but all in all it all held up really
well to the test so well done thank you
so Matt you see what we're up to how you
feeling a little nervous
thank you
[Music]
well Matt your head chilled up really
well it's still sharp the the big issue
I have is the handle all of the pins
have come loose the handle itself
isn't really glued in place would have
been worthwhile to take more time fixing
this Warp but that aside it all held
together well so good job
Joe you're up how you feeling I'm as
ready as I can be
well Joe your blade here suffered
chipping cut a big sort of dime radius
chip and then the rest of it is all
chipped as well
I think that when you were chasing this
delamination you ended up with an edge
that's on the thinner side aside from
your Blade the handle is a good size
good Dimension
um
I like the contouring
but uh there's just no denying this
chipping on the edge here yes sir
this is the sugarcane slice to test the
sharpness of your weapon I will cut
across these sugar canes Mike you're up
first you ready for this absolutely
let's do this
I'm just praying and hoping there's no
problems
all right Mike your Edge cut easily
through this sure cane it's light it's
fast it's sharp and most importantly
it will cut just
all right Matt your turn sir you ready
yes sir let's do this
foreign
first up the handle it's loosened a lot
there's a little crack and it's starting
to open up where I can see it but
despite this severe warp that you have
right here your blade is strong it's
sharp and most importantly it will cut
awesome
all right Chief you're next you ready
yes sir let's do this
I know my only chance of moving on at
this point is my blade has to perform
very well
good job
all right Chief let's talk about your
bolo here your Edge you have some
missing pieces right here but the edge
is sharp enough to cut it's wheelable
you have a good bounce here because it's
got a good handle to hold on to more
importantly sir it'll cut thank you
Airman the judges have completed their
deliberation and it's time for one of
you Smith's to leave the forge
blade Smith leaving the forge is
Joe your blade didn't make the cut
please surrender your blade
disappointed to myself that I didn't do
a better job in the first round and
wasn't able to make the corrections that
needed to be made but I feel really good
about the two Smiths moving forward
representing the Air Force I may not be
a forged and fire Champion but I had the
opportunity to come here and show some
of my skills I'm walking out with my
head held high